[Musique]
ici à freiner les chaumes dans la
commune de Pithiviers le vieil le couple
kissowska possède une galerie
extraordinaire en plein cœur de leur
jardin Fabrice et Marylise transforme
leur pavillon en une sorte de petit
musée Grévin du recyclage alors
préparez-vous à rencontrer dans ce
jardin des stars du show-business des
figures historiques et même politique
regardez chaque Pasqua Michel Rocard et
Monsieur Seguin
il apparemment sa chèvre qui était
planqué dans le coin
très très bon choix musical Charles
Trenet c'est quoi le titre de la chanson
le jardin extraordinaire ce choix est
extraordinaire
[Musique]
alors d'accord
une proportion c'est très important dans
une création on peut faire une très
belle création et tout ratée donc là
c'est pour exprimer le c'est très
sérieux
on continue alors on continue alors là
on a les endroits de la réflexion vous
les voyez là il y en a trois donc ça
c'est pour exprimer beaucoup plus la
réflexion on a aussi les créations
avec des épingles à linge tu vois c'est
ça c'est déjà les visages ça me pousse à
la réflexion si les gars
c'est que moi c'était œuvre là j'ai pas
compris mais tu comprends exactement ce
qui passe par la tête de Fabrice tout ce
qui rêve la nuit moi je le fais avec lui
[Musique]
il y a des oiseaux qui tiennent un buff
ça va nous voilà arriver à la gare tu
papi du alors ça c'est la gare de
Pithiviers transformé en musée de la
déportation inauguré par Macron je crois
en août dernier et là on a le petit
train qui imagine la rafle du beldib et
les pauvres gens emmené au camp de
Pithiviers
il y a un petit coin coquin quand même
oui il y a un petit coin coquin ici là
oui mais là la première anecdote c'est
que sont les femmes qui demandent les
premiers à rentrer dedans
c'est pas moi qui le dis c'est Fabrice
qui l'a dit bon je me retourne sur ma
gauche je vois Johnny et ici je vois
comment s'appelle gold bear
on va faire un featuring euh Johnny et
Gold et ça va donner
[Applaudissements]
quelque chose elle ne te revient pas